what's up YouTube Welcome to my chat all
right there'll be none of that here I
couldn't resist indulge me but welcome
to my channel which I've had for uh
about 12 years and which was made for
precisely this purpose to make videos
like this though I haven't for 12 years
and uh the reason is because uh truth be
told I'm a
perfectionist and when I first made the
channel even though I wanted to make
videos like this I thought uh I would
have to learn a lot of technical stuff I
thought I'd have to have per perfect
lighting perfect background all sorts of
uh other technical YouTube relevant
aspects monetizing etc etc none of which
really I've learned but I've since
learned that that doesn't really much
matter that uh just putting a camera and
talking to people directly as I'm doing
right now seems to hit the spot
According to some people so find by me
because that's a lot easier and I can
just do it
so at long last here we are with my uh
first video directed at you the Watcher
I've done many videos with interviewing
people who would interview me and call
me etc etc but this is a little
different because I'm talking to you I
guess directly and feel free to comment
I'll be uh definitely reading those and
let me know what you want to hear on
this channel what sort of topics and
videos I'll definitely take that under
consideration um so along with with why
of course uh I made this channel like I
said 12 years ago and if you look at it
you're just going to see old videos that
I've done with other people that were
just uploaded but none of this like not
these sorts of
videos um but you know
honestly the way gen Z is and not a few
Millennials making videos obviously is
the way to go um it's the preferred
medium not to mention it's very easy
this is a lot easier than what I
normally do uh if you know me I write
books and articles and that requires a
little more finesse and um articulation
and research etc etc and I'm still going
to do that of course because that's what
I enjoy personally writing uh in books
are still going to keep coming forth but
I see this as a sort of Outlet um to the
um those who would rather watch than
read let's just say and I have and
that's fine by me I understand
that as for the topics uh it'll be
essentially we'll start off with what I
know and what I'm good at what I'm known
for I'm kind of the Islam guy you know
going back to almost 20 years I think uh
my first published piece for the LA
Times about Islam was in 2005 so almost
20 years now that's what I've been
dealing with writing with um
translating um Islamic ideology Doctrine
Etc increasingly though I've gone back
to my initial academic interest which
was the Nexus
between uh Christen and Islam or really
you know whatever the historical
struggle between the west and Islam from
its first early initial stages in the
7th Century up until today as evidenced
by my more recent books sordan simitar
Defenders of the West which really look
at the history and my current book which
I'm working on which is very similar to
those but in a very unique way and we'll
talk about that when the time comes but
aside from the Islam stuff I plan on
talking about a lot more topics uh
obviously we live in a day and age where
there's a lot of things going on above
and beyond Islam Islam is still a very
important potent Force that's completely
overlooked by a lot of people in fact
because there is so much going on it's
almost uh what we have is going on is a
distraction um that needs of course be
dealt in its own terms but it's a
distraction because we don't the Islamic
imperative continues unabated in many
ways and no one's really looking at and
talking about it but along with
discussing Islam in the past and in the
present and in the future uh I hope to
eventually start talking about a lot
more relevant topics timely topics uh
that have nothing to do with Islam you
may be surprised but probably of all the
research and reading I've done over the
last few decades most of it has not been
about Islam even though even though
that's what I do uh that's essentially
my profession but there's but there's
still a lot lot of uh other historical
non-islamic philosophical theological
secular topics that one can delve in and
eventually I hope to do that if I have
the time and
inclination at any rate so there it
is um go ahead like And subscribe and
and smash that button whatever I don't
know what much of that means I do know
what subscribe means and you should do
that subscribe now and uh otherwise uh
see see you soon farewell